é é nossa tão difícil falar com tanta
gente aqui na dá mais por um mineiro que
não é da metrópole e que se tornou da
metrópole então acho que eu tenho lá
bastante qualificação para falar de vida
e metrópole porque eu não nasci na
metrópole né
e eu dividir esse tempo que eu tenho em
quatro partes né
cinco minutos de quem sou eu de onde eu
vim que meio que explica um pouco do que
eu penso
cinco minutos do que eu acredito que
seria uma vida em metrópole um pouco
mais humana e solidária
se você não gostou de nenhum desses dois
têm um videozinho muito interessante um
acabamento magnífico com legendas em
inglês para garantir e mesmo assim vocês
não gostaram de nada
tem uma frase eu tenho arrastado em
minha vida que talvez explique grande
parte dos nossos problemas aqui do da
metrópole e do nosso país né então é é a
minha vida começa a 72 em uma cidade de
20 mil habitantes no interior de minas
nessas podem notar o sotaque suíço que
eu tenho pai bancário mãe professora e
eu tive um e eu fui obrigado de três em
três anos a mudar de cidade porque o meu
pai gerente de banco tem que estar
sempre mudando
então eu tinha convicção que eu ia
perder e conquistar novos amigos de três
em três anos então me parece uma coisa
fácil mas tem uma coisa muito difícil
muito traumática vou apresentar a vocês
aqui o novo coleguinha então é difícil
você ter que estar sempre saindo do do
status curvamos falar assim
isso é me leva até os 20 anos de idade
nessa vida
mudar de três em três anos de cidade
pequena de repente eu precisava sair da
sua cidade pra fazer faculdade para
tentar ser alguém na vida né
e acabei entrando numa faculdade em são
paulo que ela 300 quilômetros da cidade
que morava
e aí começa o meu grande choque né
porque eu acabei caindo numa dança de
uma das faculdades mais elitizados é
talvez do brasil e quando eu chego eu
comecei a olhar que as meninas se
vestiram exatamente igual com o mesmo
tipo de bolsa de calça e blusa lencinho
no pescoço
os meninos se vestiu exatamente igual
com a mesma marca de tênis calça jeans
ea camiseta lá nem falar as marcas e eu
totalmente diferente né e sofri aquele
bullying criativo que não me magoava não
era divertido né
eu era totalmente diferente daquilo
quando eu voltava pra minha quitinete no
centro da cidade ao lado de uma escola
de samba 10 quadras a pé
eu ficava pensando poxa como é diferente
isso aqui como é que eu não conheço mais
o frentista do posto a pessoa da padaria
e me parece que tem um nicho fechado
aqui
aí eu precisava trabalhar só estudei em
escola pública e foi aceita uma pequena
corretora de valores no centro da cidade
em são paulo que com muito esforço nós
muita luta
cresceu muito é eu me tornei sócio e nós
vendemos um banco suíço essa empresa né
eu comecei a ver dinheiro na minha vida
que eu nunca tinha visto
espera aí é isso aqui é o dinheiro outro
lado você vai ficar olha o dinheiro você
vai ficar numa escola particular porque
os filhos
o dinheiro você vai ter acesso aos
melhores médicos aqui da capital com
dinheiro
se você tiver qualquer problema de saúde
você
mas ser tratado no no hospital
referência da américa latina
o dinheiro você vai ter um carro
importado que você quiser
blindado pode ficar tranqüilo ó nível 3
de blindagem pode atirar à vontade
que coisa diferente da vida que levava
em minas é que todo mundo era amigo
brincavam na praça do coreto
nem todo mundo se conhecia não tinha
essa história né aí outra coisa você vai
morar num condomínio guarita blindada
até pra pegar pizza habilitado e além
disso você vai frequentar sala vip do
aeroporto adeus ficar esperando o avião
igual rodoviária é sala vip
as pessoas falavam de um jeito que
parecia que era um lugar feliz entendeu
não será que esse é o conceito de
felicidade é tão diferente do que eu
tinha na investigada nessa nesse assunto
porque também incomodando muito né e
quando eu falava com as pessoas dessa
classe social que eu acabei me tornando
nem fui meio que empurrado por essa vida
em gueto que eu sempre falo né
o relógio o sapato o cinto né
e por quê que você acha legal essa vida
e o que eu mais ouvia era que é uma
forma que eu me protejo do mundo ao meu
redor da metrópole
mas por que você se protege do mundo ao
seu redor mas na minha vida no interior
eu nunca me proteger de ninguém nem eu
com comprimento todo mundo na rua eu
recebo bom dia de desconhecido né tem
casos que eu entro em prédio em são
paulo
eu falo bom dia pessoal falou assim eu
te conheço
sabe uma coisa o museu e um centro de
educação nos conhecer para dar bom dia
porque porque nas grandes cidades você
não tem a recorrência da relação e isso
é uma coisa muito diferente do interior
as pessoas tendem a serem gentis umas
com as outras num censo mais comunitário
no interior porque você tem a
recorrência da relação não pode meter a
mão na buzina um cara atrás você vai
encontrar com ele depois da igreja então
você fica meio nem falei poxa eu vou
mais devagar nas grandes cidades como
aqui como o são paulo você não tem isso
então você pode se dar ao luxo de viver
em guetos e tratar as pessoas que não
estão no seu nicho como mais um número
muitas vezes eu vejo a pessoa pede
alguma coisa o garçom quando o garçom
traz ele não sabe nem se foi aquele que
ele pediu porque apenas um vulto vestido
de branco e preto e não personalizo
daquela relação né
então é isso começou a me incomodar e
são paulo é diferente do rio porque são
paulo é uma cidade radial você fixa um
ponto no centro e nos jardins por
exemplo à medida que você expande os
quatro pontos o idh vai abaixando certo
você pegar os mapas você vê na hora o
rio é mais interessante porque o rio
você não precisa puxar radial tem um
convívio aqui na zona sul das classes
variadas por causa dos morros mas se
você expande a zona sul para o subúrbio
que vocês falam aqui você começa a ver o
idh caindo então as cidades elas foram
criadas muito focadas num nicho de idh
alto em algum lugar que expande um monte
de gente com idh baixo e tudo foi feito
para privilegiar o idh alto
lagoa tá no lugar alto tá no idh
privilegiado então é um exemplo aqui do
rio de janeiro tem várias coisas que eu
posso citar pra você do shopping center
tudo foi feito aqui né
no na zona sul então gente o que eu
iria é mudar um pouquinho aqui é que
quando eu vi que eu tinha muito pra mim
é muito dinheiro né
é eu falei poxa acho que eu vou separar
um pedaço do meu patrimônio anualmente e
desse patrimônio eu vou escolher uma
causa que realmente faça sentido pra mim
e vou devolver à sociedade
recorrentemente isso há 11 anos atrás o
que me faltava e quando começava a
conversar com as pessoas é a ausência
disso as pessoas hoje quando fazem
filantropia fazem muitas vezes
esporádico sem foco não recorrente e o
que eu venho propondo não assistiu o
vídeo é que o cara é que seja uma coisa
recorrente é quando eu decidir jogar
tudo pra cima em 2009 eu montei alguma
coisa que auxiliava as pessoas a serem
melhores filantropos muito focado na
pessoa física de alto poder aquisitivo
que também abre para qualquer classe e
com isso criar um legado familiar e com
isso criar uma sociedade mais justa e
com isso criar a empatia pelo outro que
está fora do mito né
essa é minha a minha bandeira né eu
tenho aqui pra mudar um pouco de d
só eu falando né eu fiz a gente tem um
vídeo interessante que foi dodô outro de
um outro evento que eu acho que vale a
pena dar uma olhada uma coisa de três
minutos é muito mais bonito eu falando
que aqui que eu tô não é um tremendo de
falar para tanta gente qualificada aqui
o vídeo de três minutos só é muito
interessante conta um pouco do que eu
acredito tá
o instituto ase ele atua
inicialmente descobrindo potenciais
investidores sociais doadores
depois disso a gente vai descobrir que é
o trabalho mais longo se ele é outro
estou não se descobre que ele
minimamente gostaria de fazer alguma
coisa pelo próximo
a gente vai descobrir que causa está
dentro dele
esse projeto é pioneiro no brasil porque
a gente descobre a causa que realmente
está dentro da pessoa
você liga por ação com bolsa se você não
descobre a causa só tem que sair do
bolso a quantidade de dinheiro que está
exclusivamente do bolso é menor
interligado com a banda larga do coração
a gente está trabalhando é aquela causa
que está dentro de você
profundamente aquela que você chora
quando vê você tem um amigo nosso grande
empresário não tinha tanto foco em
altruísmo de repente pulga nasce um
filho autista com condição ele vai lá e
contrata os melhores médicos o garoto
super bem
a companhia escola super bem fazem por
aí e os outros
monto uma organização social ajuda 100
crianças por mês com 1 milhão de reais
do bolso por ano
se você descobre claramente quem é
aquela pessoa onde você vai colocar o
dinheiro fica muito mais fácil porque
você sabe exatamente o risco que ele
suporta correr transfere isso a área
social
se eu descubra qual é a causa foi o
montante fica muito mais fácil porque eu
sei claramente um envolvimento que ele
vai ter a filantropia é a consequência
da pessoa turista que uma pessoa
altruísta né quatro coisas básicas
ela doa uma parcela considerável do seu
património eu uso um por cento do meu
patrimônio para viver
um por cento do meu patrimônio é
filantropia é considerável a um para um
é um prêmio ao filho é um menino da maré
porque há pessoas existem 100 milhões de
reais que você faz
ah eu pagar a faculdade do medo do filho
empregado irrelevante não é altruísta
recorrente não é uma vez na vida
ano após ano impessoal
eu não sei pra que eu tô dando quem está
recebendo não sabe que fui eu que dei eu
fiz 600 casas
eu não tenho ideia quem são as pessoas e
eles também não sabem que foi o último
sem visar nenhuma consequência para mim
eu não faço isso para agradar o meu
sócio e eu não faço isso porque eu tenho
sentido fiscal
enfim eu não vejo nenhuma consequência
para mim isso é a raiz do altruísmo
vai ser mais né mas bem feito que eu
falar aqui pra vocês né
nos últimos três minutos que eu tenho eu
queria só dividir com vocês uma
inquietação já que é bem é instigante
que eu tentei consolidar numa numa frase
que eu acredito que é um grande problema
nosso é no brasil em algumas cidades
também é de outros lugares que eu queria
que essa fase aparecesse aqui agora eu
vou explicar para vocês
anorexia da ética permissiva aqui
palavrão que é esse né então eu quero
falar para vocês nós brasileiros fica
mais fácil de entender
a gente tem ética
com o tempo ela foi ficando anoréxica
ela foi diminuindo na em vários assuntos
nós vamos falar só de um específico e
permissível permissível é o pior porque
às vezes a pessoa tem anorexia da ética
mas o meio que ela vive não permite que
ela seja assim
isso é muito diferente dois exemplos e
conclua quiné 11 é um caminhão de
achocolatado que tomba na rodovia
anhanguera de são paulo ae o morador
desce da comunidade saqueia o caminhão
de achocolatado e chega em casa e fala
assim vamos comer chocolatado o resto do
ano para aí ok
as duas primeiras palavras param aqui
qual a reação da família mão direito
devolva imediatamente não é seu você não
pode fazer isso mão direita
maravilha dezinho vamos chamar os
familiares
isso é permissível essa é a anorexia da
ética pm se você permite a falta de
ética
transfira isso pra
ponto na carteira de motorista está numa
festa eu só vou falar pra você assim
marcos flávio contra um despachante que
tira ponto da carteira mão esquerda eu
nunca mais vou falar com você
isso é um absurdo é repugnante e eu vou
denunciá lo
o telefone dele pra mim
entenda isso explica uma dezena de
problemas que nós enfrentamos o nosso
país porque a tendência a falta de ética
ela cresce no mundo à medida que ele se
torna mais individualista a
permissibilidade dela é que acaba
matando uma sociedade tão gentil
agradeço muito o tempo de vocês a
paciência obrigado